DOLLARS FOR DOING NOTHING.
MAYBE YOU GET GUILTY AND HAVE A
LOT OF FREE TIME ANYWAY STAY.
NOW THE CONSTANT DEMOCRATIC
STRUGGLES IS WHY DEVAL PATRICK,
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG ARE MAKING A
LAST-DITCH BID FOR THE DESPERATE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THAT TRUMP IS ON THE PATH
TO VICTORY.
BY THE WAY, MICHAEL BLOOMBERG'S
CAMPAIGN MANAGER JUST FLAT OUT
ADMITTED IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE POLLS,
AND PEOPLE CAN'T FOCUS ON THIS.
THE GENERAL ELECTION IS IN SIX
DAYS.
IT IS IN WISCONSIN, MICHIGAN,
PENNSYLVANIA, NORTH CAROLINA,
FLORIDA, AND ARIZONA.
THAT IS THE WHOLE ENTIRE GENERAL
ELECTION.
AND RIGHT NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
WINNING THAT ELECTION.
IT IS VERY TOUGH FOR PEOPLE WHO
DO NOT TO LIVE IN NEW YORK AND
CALIFORNIA TO UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING.
>> Sean: IN 343 DAYS, YOU, WE,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU GET THE
FINAL SAY.
ONE END IT BE COOL TO SHOCK THE
WORLD AGAIN?
JUST SHOCK THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA.
HOW GREAT WOULD IT BE ON
ELECTION NIGHT, THEY HAVE TO
SAY, DONALD TRUMP IS REELECTED
THE 45TH PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
HE WOULD PROBABLY CRACK UNDER
THE PRESSURE.
THE FORMER WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY SARAH SANDERS,
34.5, AND 34% AFRICAN-AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES, SIX SEPARATE POLLS,
THE LOWEST ONE HAD THE PRESIDENT
HAD DOUBLED THE NUMBER HE HAD IN
2016, IF THAT LOAN NUMBER HOLDS,
TO ME, MY ANALYSIS, THAT WOULD
MEAN GAME OVER.
IT'S DONE.
PRESIDENT HAS SERVED THE
MINORITY COMMUNITIES BETTER THAN
THE EIGHT YEARS OF BIDEN-OBAMA.
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE, YOUTH UNEMPLOYMENT.
I GUESS THE NARRATIVE THAT
REPUBLICANS ARE RACIST, SEXIST,
HOMOPHOBIC IS NOT TRUE, IS IT?
>> NOT AT ALL.
CERTAINLY NOT AS PRESIDENT.
I'M JUST GLAD TO SEE THAT THERE
IS FINALLY COME I NEVER THOUGHT
I WOULD SAY THIS, SEAN.
BUT I FINALLY THINK THAT ONE
THOUGH THAT THE DEMOCRATS HAS
FIGURED IT OUT.
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG'S CAMPAIGN
MANAGER ACTUALLY GOT SOMETHING
RIGHT.
AND ADMITTED IT.
DONALD TRUMP IS WINNING.
AND ALL OF AMERICA IS WINNING.
AND THAT'S WHY HIS NUMBERS
CONTINUE TO GO UP.
IT IS JUST AMAZING TO SEE THAT
SOMEBODY FROM THEIR SIDE IS
ACTUALLY ADMITTING IT AND
TALKING ABOUT IT PUBLICLY.
AND I THINK THAT IF THOSE
NUMBERS STAY AND HOLD WHERE THEY
ARE EVEN AS A BASELINE, IT'S NOT
JUST GAME OVER, BUT THIS IS A
LANDSLIDE VICTORY FOR THIS
PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: IF YOU HAD TO
GUESS --
>> AND I THINK AMERICA --
>> Sean: I THINK THE PLAN IS
THAT THE OBAMA, I DON'T KNOW,
SUPPORTERS, THEY HAVE THE I
GUESS THEIR OWN LITTLE
INSTITUTION, THOUGH SUPPORTERS
OF HIS.
THEY ARE COALESCING AROUND DEVAL
PATRICK, AND I SAY THAT FOR A
LOT OF REASONS.
DAVE ALEXA WALL SUPPORT, THE
COMMENTS ARE TOO EXTREME.
NOW THE MORE RECENT COMMENTS, DO
YOU BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE NOW
TRYING TO SUPPORT HIM IN THE
LAST-MINUTE PUSH HERE?
>> I THINK THEY ARE DESPERATELY
TRYING TO FIND SOMEBODY WHO CAN
ACTUALLY RUN A REAL CAMPAIGN.
SO FAR EVERYTHING WE HAVE SEEN
OUT OF THE DEMOCRATIC FIELD DOES
NOTHING BUT MAKE EVERY
REPUBLICAN IN THIS COUNTRY
EXTREMELY HAPPY, BECAUSE IT IS
CLEAR THAT DONALD TRUMP IS GOING
TO WIN REELECTION.
ANYBODY WHO IS PAINFULLY SET AND
WATCHED EACH OF THE DEMOCRATIC
DEBATES KNOWS THAT JOE BIDEN IS
AN INCREDIBLY WEAK CANDIDATE.
AND HE IS THEIR FRONT RUNNER.
HE IS TIED UP IN CORRUPTION
SCANDAL AFTER SCANDAL, AND HE
STILL IS CONSIDERED THE FRONT
RUNNER.
AND HE IS A TERRIBLE CANDIDATE.
AND EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT
INCLUDING FORMER PRESIDENT OH
BIDEN, WHO HAD A MASSIVE
VICE PRESIDENT FOR EIGHT YEARS.
IT IS A SAD DAY WHEN YOU CAN'T
GET THAT GUY TO HELP SUPPORT YO
YOU.
>> Sean: ARE YOU MAKING PIES
FOR THANKSGIVING?
BECAUSE I REMEMBER THE MOB IN
THE MEDIA DOUBTED IF YOU MADE
PIES.
NU ACTUALLY MADE THEM SOME AND
THEY DID NOT DESERVE IT.
MAYBE IF YOU ACCIDENTALLY, I'M
KIDDING, I'M KIDDING.
>> NEVER WOULD HAVE DONE THAT,
BUT I AM DEFINITELY MAKING MORE
PIES AND HOSTING THANKSGIVING AT
MY HOUSE THIS YEAR.
SEAN, I WILL BE SURE TO TWEET A
FEW OF THOSE OUT FOR YOU.
>> Sean: WE LIVE IN THE
GREATEST COUNTRY GOD GAVE MAN.
THE GREATEST MILITARY DEFENDING
US.
AND THANK YOU, AND I WISH YOU
AND YOUR FAMILY AND YOUR DAD A
HAPPY THANKSGIVING.